it was a great interview from the series
creator of Dahmer this would be Ryan
Murphy and I started watching Dahmer I
thought it was a good show sweet little
Elisa couldn't get that into it you know
it's a little grizzly
I won't spoil the story but Jeffrey
Dahmer had a not very pleasant life
difficult to watch it and girls in
particular you know get a little
squeamish with it so
Ryan Murphy
I came under Fire because the Dahmer
series was listed as as an lgbtq Series
so they have all these tags on Netflix
and the various streaming platforms they
say this is horror or this is a rom-com
or this is an LGBT show and so with with
Jeffrey Dahmer who's one of the most
notorious serial killers in psychosexual
sadists in human history it listed it as
LGBT because he was a gay guy and he
only attacked guys and and mostly black
guys specifically I don't think it was
listed as an African-American piece of
entertainment but it was listed as LGBT
and there was an uproar because they
said oh how dare you lump in Jeffrey
Dahmer with LGBT
sexual identity has everything to do
with everything
unless the guy does something bad and
then it has nothing to do with it at all
so Ryan Murphy dismissed this criticism
he said my job as an artist is to hold
up a mirror about what happened
it's ugly it's not pretty do you want to
look at it if you do watch it if you
don't look away and sometimes some of
this outrage is directed at the frame of
the mirror instead of the reflection wow
hardcore stuff
does this mean that Ryan Murphy is a
homophobe he just set out to smear gay
guys and well no because
Ryan Murphy is a gay guy
he says I think that it got the LGBT tag
one because of my involvement I'm a gay
man so most of my stories deal with some
sort of lgbtq thing and I do that
selfishly when I was growing up I had
nothing to look to
my mission statement has been to talk
about those stories and those characters
in Unearthed varied history
she was saying yeah it's probably just
because of me because I'm a gay guy and
sometimes if there's an LGBT director
then they'll put the tag too he says and
I I am selfish as an artist in that I am
interested in the LGBT idea and so I
tell stories about that and I don't only
tell really pretty stories where it's
all Will and Grace you know everything
about LGBT is always wonderful and fun
and gay I mean even the word gay became
a euphemism for LGBT because gay used to
mean happy and now gay is almost never
used in that sense like the song you
know I feel pretty or so pretty I feel
pretty and witty and gay
which I I am certain is about to be
clipped out for a meme and that's fine I
don't care that's all right
used to mean that now all it means is
LGBT
well what he's saying is no there's bad
stuff that happens all throughout the
world there's no group of people
that is immune from bad stuff and bad
characteristics
but that is contrary to what the culture
says in our culture all gay things have
to be perfectly good
all traditional things have to be
perfectly bad
if they make a show or a movie about
Africa
specifically about black Africa I guess
they could they could make a negative
movie or show about
white colonization of Africa and they've
made a lot of those but about Africa and
Africans and traditional African
societies it always has to be wonderful
if they make a movie about
the Americas before the arrival of the
Europeans it always has to be wonderful
America before the evil white man got
here it was all just this Pocahontas
have you ever seen the colors of the
rainbow in the then the Europeans get
there and they ruin everything the only
guy who can make a movie suggesting
that indigenous societies maybe weren't
all gumdrops and Roses would be Mel
Gibson that movie would be Apocalypto
it's a much more realistic view of
things but in our culture
we have decided certain groups and
certain ideas and certain societies
can only be good
those happen to be
non-western societies
you see this breakdown everywhere gay
good straight bad
woman good man bad
every race of people on Earth good white
people bad
East
the Far East the middle east Southeast
Africa good the West bad
and and when you transgress those lines
in either direction if you suggest that
maybe maybe indigenous Society or maybe
LGBT culture or maybe any of these
things might have some problems with it
you will be written off and if you
suggest that the Europeans ever did
anything good that maybe Christianity
has something to recommend it you you
will you will also falleth out of that
culture as well that's just the rule has
nothing to do with reality
has nothing to do with holding up a
mirror in in fact in some cases
it's probably because people do not like
what they see in the mirror they don't
like what they see in themselves and so
there always have to be other Pro every
bad thing that befalls anybody has to be
somebody else's fault you can never take
a look at the man in the mirror we've
also got
a magician coming up on the member block
right now a magician who pulled off one
of the most impressive magic tricks of
the year go check it out if you're not a
member
you got to join click the link in the
description and join us
[Music]
[Music]